hello everyone i'm harm van baekel i'm
an assistant professor in the department
of genetics and genomic sciences
at icann school of medicine at mount
sinai
and i will be talking to you today about
the use of genomic technologies to
understand
the dynamics of the covate19 epidemic
and in particular i will show something
about the dynamics of the epidemic
in new york city so the work
that i will highlight today would not
have been possible
um without the pathogen surveillance
program in the montana health system
so this is a program that we established
in 2014
and the goal of this program is really
to do very broad surveillance of
positive
clinical specimens within our health
system
and to look at dna sequencing of those
specimens and to perform whole genome
analysis
to track noisy communal infections and
to understand
better the spread and evolution of
pathogens in the new york city
region to date we have
uh collected roughly 100 000 specimens
from the eight different hospitals in
our system
and these include about 25 000
nasopharyngeal swabs from viral
infections as well
um we of course combine all of this
information with
uh detailed reports from the
electromagnetic record system
that are provided by a clinical
microbiology laboratory
and these include patient demographics
visit information
outcome information and allow us to
combine the genomic sequencing data with
very detailed epidemiological records
today we have analyzed about thousand
pathogen genomes
um initially our focus was very much on
uh methicillin resistant staph aureus so
mrsa
as well as clostridium difficile but in
recent years we have also focused on
influenza a and influenza b infections
within our health system
and of course more recently surgical v2
in particular as well
um just to give some background
information about our health system
so the system consists of eight
different hospitals
uh with almost 4 000 beds in total but
also 400
ambulatory sites and between um
those hospitals and ambulatory sites we
cover about four million patient visits
and we cover a very broad area of new
york city including all of the major
boroughs of the
metropolitan area there's about 15 000
inpatient admissions per year as well
um and of course all the work that we
that we started
in in doing our pathogen surveillance
program uh radically changed
when the first cases of source code v2
were detected in new york city
and these are actually detected within
our health system so the first case was
identified on february 29th
which we dubbed new york one
and the second case was then identified
on march 1st which we built in new york
too
and both of these initial cases we
sequenced within
about two weeks and deposited their data
as the first genomic data from new york
state
in the gis aid database and this is a
large public database
that is used by labs all around the
world to
essentially deposit genomic data from
the cases that they have seen in their
respective health systems and this is a
very useful repository because we can
use it to
identify our cases and place them in a
more
global phylogenetic background
so this is exactly what we did for the
first two cases
so on the left here i'm showing a final
genetic tree
that shows the position of the new york
one so the first patient isolate that we
sequenced
this was an individual with a known
travel history to the middle east and
when we look
at astrology and activity we can see
that this particular case
indeed clustered in this tree with other
specimens
from patients with travel histories to
the middle east
on the right we can see the same thing
for the new york two case
which clustered in the tree together
with other cases from spain so
essentially all the groupings industry
all the branches of this tree
denote highly related cases of specimens
and we can use that to track
and to position sequences that we saw
here in the city and
contrast them with other areas in the
world
so these two first cases really gave us
uh an excellent opportunity
to to sort of set up and trial our um
sequencing and assembly pipelines and
the workflow that we established
is shown in this slide over here where
our workflow essentially starts with rna
from
specimens testing policy for source code
v2 and then we have a variety of
sequencing technologies including
illumina
backbio iron torrent and min iom that we
deploy based
on needs so some of these technologies
give us fractal throughput
uh and quick turnaround times other
technologies maybe take a little bit
longer but you can do high throughput
sequencing
so we deployed these tools as needed and
they give us either consensus genomes
which we can
as i said indicated earlier place in a
larger
phylogeny so that you can study them in
relation to the global background
um we can also call mutations and
variants in the consensus sequence and
identify mobile variants of interest
or we can do inter-host analysis to see
whether there are maybe minor variants
presence within the host that did not
dominate in the final consensus sequence
so to date we have sequenced more than
5000 stars could be two genomes
of which more than two and a half
thousand um in new york city
alone so with
with these pipelines we were essentially
off to the races
so what i'm showing here is the
distribution
of source code v2 positive tests that we
have encountered in our health system
so there is the big major early pandemic
peak that we saw in
middle of march and early april of 2020
last year then the rates went down and
were actually quite low during the
summer of last year and then we saw an
increase in rates again towards the end
of summer and the beginning of fall
and this continues throughout the winter
of last year
um what is also very interesting here is
that i juxtaposed
the source code v2 positive rates um
with those of influenza alien influenza
b and you can really see
the big difference that we had in the
number of circle v2 cases
uh and the influenza cases of the the
final flu season
and what was particularly remarkable is
that within a period of three weeks we
have
roughly the same number of stars for v2
cases as we had seen of
influenza throughout the six-month
seasonal influenza period between
november
of 2019 and april of 2020.
um so the
the initial uh interest that we had in
these cases were to look at
these very early cases um in the initial
pandemic peak so
we we knew that there was a very high
influx of novel cases in new york city
but we didn't know where these cases
actually originated from
so what we did is essentially expand
beyond the first two cases that we had
sequenced and do an analysis
of the first 84 cases that we encounter
in our health system
so we then did a very similar analysis
to the first two cases that i that i
showed earlier
and what that essentially told us is
that most of the initial cases that we
saw in our city
originated from europe approximately 80
percent
of the isolates that we had sequenced
were very similar to cases that
um that were also sequencing europe
during that time and what i told you
that
most of the initial introductions of the
virus in new york city
um were related to traverse between
europe and new york so this could be
tourists visiting new york but also
returning travelers
that returned to home in addition to the
introductions from europe we also saw
a small number of domestic introductions
so those were
mostly related to the initial cases that
were detected in the us
within washington saw sporadic cases
linked to the middle east and asia but
the really dominant introductions really
originated in europe the other striking
observation is that
we saw those cases all throughout the
city which meant that
the introduction of the virus was
equivalent
in all the different borrowers in the
city as well
so although this told us something about
where the virus originated from
that came from new york city it didn't
really tell us much about
when the virus was introduced into the
city so
based on the phylogenetic tree and based
on the
time times analysis of these
phylogenetic trees
we can make a rough influence to when
the virus first arrived to the city
and we can do this by looking at the
mutation rate of the virus and looking
for the
time to the last common ancestor to the
dominant ice look that we saw here in
new york city
and what that told us is that the most
likely introduction was somewhere
between late january
and mid february but that time when it
was still fairly broad
and the reason why it is broad is
because the mutation rate of surgical v2
is fairly low
so from average about two mutations
every month and that means that our
influences are
limited to a two to four week period of
time
um luckily one of our collaborators mia
cerrillo from the clinical micro lab
here at mount sinai hospital
had the foresight to start accumulating
two interesting sets of samples
beginning in early january of 2020
uh one cent was a series of three
thousand
banked respiratory pathogen negative
specimens
so these were essentially specimens from
individuals that sought care
in our health system um but that that's
a
negative for known respiratory virus
infection so these were people with
respiratory
disease symptoms but not just a negative
for for example
influenza during that period of time uh
and by
essentially taking another look at the
series of samples without screening for
the presence of surgical v2 it could
tell us something
about molecular evidence of search going
to rna within the city
the second set of samples was a series
of more than ten thousand plasma samples
that were taken from montana hospital
patients
and these samples were divided into two
different subsets so we had one set of
urgent care
samples so these were plasma samples
taken from people that
visited for example emergency
departments and that sought acute care
and these were likely arranged for
um acute source could be two in fact in
particular during
um the early pandemic peak which was uh
during which time
the the regular care was also used quite
considerably
we also had a second group of patients
so these were in the routine care
group these were people coming in for
follow-up appointments for for example
prenatal testing
and these more closely represented the
general population
and these two sample cells were roughly
50 50
distributed so i'll show you some of the
results of the cross-sectional analysis
first
um so the two plots that i'm showing
here on the left
are the results for the urgent care
group and these were essentially
our positive controls for this analysis
and then on the right
are the same results now for the routine
care group so what we see for the urgent
care group is that
consistent with the early pandemic peaks
or the early surge of the virus
in late march and then beginning of
april we see that
very closely reflected within the zero
positivity
of our panel with an offset of about two
weeks which is the time
that it takes for um for antibody
responses to become
uh undetectable um
what we then see is that during the
summer months when we saw very few acute
cases
we see this frequency reduced to about
20 to 25
at the same time we also see a similar
increase in the routine care group
this is a more gradual increase until
about mid april
at which point um the the frequency
levels off to about 20
which is very similar to what we saw
during the summer months for the urgent
care group as well
so what these data tell us are two
things first
is that during the first spanish peak
about one in five new yorkers were
exposed
to the virus what it also tells us if we
look at the early period
between february and mid-march is that
there was
between two percent um
up to two percent of cases uh had
already evidence of prior infections
with govid19
so we don't know whether these
individuals were
exposed while they were in new york or
where they were exposed
prior to for example travel to new york
but it does tell us that there was
already detectable
serial converted individuals within the
city during the month of
february so of course we wanted to back
this up with molecular evidence
uh to see whether we could detect the
presence of virus
uh within uh the same patient
populations and for this we use the
second set of samples so these were the
3000 samples
of individuals that tested negative for
no respiratory various pathogens
and that we then pulled in sets of 10
and
re-screened on the roche cobalt system
to do an rtq pcr for code to
vital rna so this particular test has
two different probes
t1 and t2 each of which target a
different region of the surgical v2
genome
and we essentially identified positive
samples that had
detection of both of those targets as
well as presumptive positive
pools that have detection of at least
one of those targets
and we followed up both types of samples
so the results of that are shown here so
um
between january and march we tested
consecutive weeks
and the numbers here indicate the total
numbers of pools tested
and at the top of these bars we can see
how many presumptive positive
and how many positive samples were
detected
um we can look at that in a little bit
more detail so we're just highlighting
the percent of positive and opposite
specimens
you can see that the earliest detections
were as early as the
week ending in january 18th and january
25th
but the bulk of detections really come
at the end of february
and at the beginning of march we then
did additional sequencing of those
samples because of course we wanted a to
validate
um that these symbols indeed had viral
rna present parallel genomic rna present
but we also wanted to see if we could
reconstruct the genomes
and add them to the phylogenies of these
initial cases that we had already
profiled
um and the results of the sequencing are
shown here
so we had essentially uh several of the
initial samples confirmed
from the week ending in january 25th as
well as the week uh ending in february
first
so all those samples we were not able to
obtain complete genomes but we did
detect the presence of viral rna which
validates that we indeed have protection
b2 vital rna during this period of time
and then in the later sample sets from
the weeks ending on february 29th
as well as the weekend on march 7th we
were able to obtain complete genomes so
we then took those genomes
and placed them within the larger
phylogenetic tree of storage flow v2
and what that showed us is that in
addition to these early detections that
we saw on the weekend
january 25th and the weekend on the
february 1st
that we were not able to place in the
tree because we didn't obtain a complete
genome
we do see the in red here different
bulbs in red
the complete genomes that we obtained
prior to the surge of cases that are
highlighted here in yellow
that occurred mostly in march the
mid-march to end of march
of uh 2020. and what that tells us is
that
we have the earliest detection in the
week of january 25th but also that we
have multiple detections
between our sort of initial positive
cases that were identified based on
non-travel history
and the surge of cases that we saw in
mid-march
once the detection capability
so our ability to detect source code v2
at
higher numbers uh actually came online
so we had a brief window of time of
maybe about two weeks that if we had
uh widespread testing online earlier we
could have
detected communities but
prior to the large surge that we saw in
the weeks
proceeding
so of course we have not sit still since
the initial detection of source code v2
uh we have continued our surveillance in
the new york area
uh we have done this now for uh for over
a year and we're sequencing
at the at the weekly frequency uh
covering approximately 10
of positive specimens that are detected
in
monsanto healthcare system um and what
this has told us essentially is that
while our initial detections were very
homogeneous so we saw most of the
initial introductions
related to european travelers
predominantly made up of the
one branch of the three which is the 20c
clade
but the current picture is much more
diverse we see much more diversity
and we see really a broad representation
of
um different languages that are
circulating globally
and we are encountering all the
different lineages here in new york city
which is not surprising considering that
we are a major travel hub and that we
have
very broad connections with many parts
of the world
and is also consistent with the opening
up gradual opening up of the city
since late summer and until
the winter season
so the hardware landscape in in the city
has not only been
shaped by these various introductions
that i already highlighted
what we also see is that local spread
has contributed significantly to the
landscape here
and one nice example of this is the b
1.1.304 lineage which is one of the
branches in the tree
of starscore v2 which i've shown here at
the top
we first see this lineage emerge in the
fall of 2020
and then we sort of see it gradually
increase over time
and to become the dominant strength that
we observed here in our healthcare
patients during late summer and early
fall
what we did is not only track this in
time so we not only can see this
emergence of the strain and tracker we
can also track it over space which is
what we have done here
and what we can see is essentially that
while this lineage started very locally
so it started in one area of brooklyn
um if we track it over time you can see
that
it begins to slowly expand first locally
but then
also throughout other parts of the city
and this is
i think a really nice example of a super
spreader event
that then later concede multiple
cases throughout a wider region
as well
more recently we have become
increasingly interested in tracking
variants so these are
variants of starscore v2 that carry
mutations
uh in the receptor binding domain but
also other regions of the virus
the receptor binomial is of course very
important because the area
of the spike protein which is the vital
receptor
that the virus uses to
gain energy into host cells and the rbd
the receptor binder domain is
responsible for interactions with the
ace2
host cell receptor and this introduction
is key to gaining entry into those cells
what we've seen now emerge over the last
several months
is an increased number of mutations in
this domain
and these mutations could for example
impact the interaction with the host
receptor
but it could also impact interactions
with antibodies
that could neutralize this intervention
and of course this could lead the virus
to
to have reduced susceptibility to for
example vaccination or previous immunity
i should know though that um during
vaccination
people are inoculated with the entire
spike protein
so that also induces lots of antibodies
that target other regions despite
protein
and it is currently no evidence
or currently that the vaccines remain
broadly protected even against these new
viral variants
um so for the last part of my
presentation uh i wanted to highlight
also some of the work that we have been
doing to track
transmissions and outbreaks uh of source
code v2
um and we have done this using tools
that we've developed for this purpose
and in particular
the one that i'm highlighting here is
the pathospot tool which is something
that we developed to
to do whole genome alignments of viral
genomes
or bacterial genomes and then to use
genome similarity to identify clusters
of highly related isolates
and integrate the clusters of those
isolates
with detailed epidemiological
information all the patients that these
isolates have been identified in
and to plot timelines of infection
and to use those timelines to then
delineate the origins of particular
objects and transmissions
so we did this in early 2019 for an
influenza a outbreak
in one of the hospitals in our system
and what we were able to identify there
is that
for a large outbreak that impacted
approximately
100 patients and healthcare providers
were able to trace that outbreak
to a single exposure event in the
emergency department
that impacted three patients and one
healthcare worker
and when those patients and healthcare
worker then proceeded to
transfer to other areas in hospital they
essentially brought the virus with them
and spread the outbreak among larger
numbers of patients and healthcare
workers so i think this
this is a very nice illustration of how
uh whole genome sequencing can
precisely delineate who is part of an
outbreak and that is very important in
tracking
some of these early early events
so we were then able to um to use
these tools um in a variety of different
settings
one of these is to study um
transmissions among
marine recruits during supervised
quarantine
so obviously um early on in the pandemic
it became clear
for the military that they had to
instantiate
um quarantine and procedures to
to reduce the risk of outbreaks in for
example training facilities
and to reduce impact on military
readiness
so the quarantine schedule that was
devised for this
at the marine corps recruiting depot in
paris island
um was to subject new recruits to a
two-week self-quarantine
at home um prior to them traveling to
the recruit
depot and then follow this by testing on
arrival
and then do additional testing in week
one and v2 after arrival
during a supervised quarantine so this
was
pcr testing which tests for the presence
of viral rna
and then liquids were only allowed to
enter in the basically tested
negative after week two of surveillance
so these uh we essentially followed for
this cohort
classes of 350 to 450 recruits that
arrived
weekly and we looked at a total of nine
classes
there were no interactions between
classes so each of them should be
quite well separated and then each of
the classes during the supervised
quarantine
i was instructed to use mask social
distancing to perform treatment hand
washing and each of the participants in
our study
was housed with a single roommate so
basically all um available public health
measures were
were taken to ensure that the risk of
transmission was reduced as much as
possible during the supervised
quarantine
so in total there were approximately
1800 study participants and these were
drawn from recruits
that mostly came from the east coast
as highlighted over here um
and then among the participants we saw
that
20 of them were positive for saraswati
on arrival for the supervised
quarantine and although the vast
majority 95 percent were asymptomatic
and this really highlights very clearly
especially in young adult cohorts
the need for widespread testing as many
of the cases
will will elude detection during
due to asymptomatic carriage um
then in a subsequent week so these the
first 20 participants were identified
upon arrival
in the subsequent two weeks we
identified another 31 participants that
tested positive
during their quarantine period and these
can either be specimens that were missed
on the initial screening
or they can signify transmission during
the two-week
quarantine of these
51 cases we identified genomes or we
obtained genomes for about 32
participants which is about
63 of the positive specimens
we then took those uh complete genomes
and we placed them
within the larger phylogeny of surgical
v2
at the time so basically on the left
there is the
the phylogenetic tree that gives an
overview of the global diversity of
ceroscopy 2 with the different lineages
that were circulating
at the time of the study and then you
can see with the different
uh circles of different colored circles
within the tree
um that the the positive specimens that
we identified among the study
participants
um broadly clustered throughout this
tree and that's
very um consistent with the broad
catchment area of the east coast that
study participants were drawn from what
is also very striking is that
within this larger background diversity
we did event
identify multiple clusters of specimens
that were highly related to each other
and that suggests to us that these were
part of transmissions and outbreaks
during the quarantine period i've
highlighted two clusters among those so
cluster two and cluster five which were
two of the largest classes we identified
during the study period um and if we
look at those
in in more detail and map them actually
to the room layout
uh that these were housed in we can
actually see that those two clusters
um were identified among two different
platoons so platoon f
and platoon e that are housed together
on the same floor
of the quarantine building
and they shared with any splatoon
participants shared rooms and pairs
and what is interesting to note is that
both classes were contained within
platoons
um and that there was no sharing of
individuals between platoons except for
two cases where one individual from each
platoon were housed in the same
warehouse in the same room so the other
takeaway that most of the young adult
cases here were asymptomatic and that
again
highlights that asymptomatic spread is
very important
is a very important factor in young
adult settings
and that wise broadcasting is really
needed to identify those cases
the other general take home here is that
shared accommodation
and sort of long-term shared rooms are
really important factor in sales machine
as well
so we have now taken some of those
lessons and have applied them
in our health system as well so we've
used similar approaches to
investigate multiple suspected
non-communal events uh starting an
august in august of 2020 um
we have identified multiple um noise
hormonal clusters and and
have been able to use genomic uh
analysis to precisely delineate whose
sparking was not part of these clusters
and again similar to the outbreak that
we had investigated in early 2019
it allows us to identify potential
exposure events
that precipitated some of these larger
outbreaks
with that i'll come to my conclusion so
with the data that i've shown today
um there is evidence from many multiple
introductions into the new york city
metropolitan area
um initial introductions were as early
as the end of january
although we did not think that these
initial introductions uh
resulted in forward spread based on the
fact that we only saw
a larger panamic peak towards the middle
of
may um
so the early transmission events that we
identified in the early communities
productively identified
mostly tracked back to cases that were
identified in europe and that indicates
that travelers from europe are
responsible for most of the initial
spreading
of sourceboard v2 in new york city but
over time these patterns have changed
quite considerably
and we think that these reflect patterns
in the different differences in the
patterns of international
domestic and local introductions that
also came with the opening up of the
city
as well as a continued community spread
that have shaped the viral landscape in
the city
we to track closely the emergence of new
mutations and variants of concern
which really requires a continuous
monitoring by genomic surveillance and
we see in particular for example the uk
variant and the b1.526 variant that are
free gained prominence in new york city
um in the earlier months of 2021
um and finally by doing outbreak
analysis we've also shown that
widespread testing is
key to track asymptotic transmissions
and that is in particular
of importance in young adult group
settings
and the similar tools can also be highly
useful for precision surveillance in
nautical settings
and with that i just want to acknowledge
the large number of
of people that have contributed to this
work of course this was a major group
effort
that involved not only my lab but also
viviana simone's lab
the clinical microbiology team at
mount sinai at the montana health system
and in particular emilia cedello
freudian killer florian kramer's lamp
that was responsible for all the
psychology testing
and then finally the work that they
showed on the
marine recruitment cohort was done in
collaboration with the cell phone lab
as well as the naval medical research
center and with that
i will end my presentation